[Applause]
India became the world's first nation to
reach the South Pole of the Moon on
August 23rd
India is now on the moon people are
applauding Mission Control erupted in
cheers as the chantayan 3 landed in a
part of the Moon where no country has
ever landed before for India it's a
matter of national pride
it happened just three days after a
similar Mission from Russia failed it's
a blow to the Kremlin because they are
trying to show through this mission that
Russia is again a superpower the lunar
South Pole is significant because the
expected presence of ice could support
future human settlements
here's why Moscow and New Delhi were in
a race to get there and how their
missions were not just about science but
also about politics
[Music]
[Applause]
India's chandrayaan III which means Moon
vehicle in Sanskrit blasted off from
Earth on July 14th of normal since then
this spacecraft made several Maneuvers
around the earth and has been orbiting
the moon to prepare for our Landing
Russia launched its lunar 25 less than a
month later it took a much faster and
more direct routes to the moon and was
projected to reach the surface First on
August 21st
the South Pole is strategic because the
expected presence of ice could provide
fuel oxygen and drinking water making it
a potential site for Mining and human
settlements but experts say a smooth
Landing is extremely challenging that's
because the area has much tougher
terrain compared to other parts of the
Moon it is Bumpy littered with craters
and has limited sunlight
Lander module has begun its descent
India Tried by failed to reach there
four years ago and finally succeeded on
August 23rd
this success
it will help
Moon missions
by other countries in the future that
makes India the fourth country in the
world to reach the moon after the United
States Russia and China India is
expected to get a lot of offers from
other space agencies foreign countries
to launch like commercial satellites for
them which is going to be also Revenue
earner for India
a happy Landing for Russia's unmanned
lunar 17 spacecraft Russia was the first
country to send a Rover to the Moon back
in 1970. towards the end of a space race
between the U.S and the Soviet Union
during the Cold War but Russia hasn't
launched another lunar lander since the
1970s and the stakes this time around
were especially High more than 18 months
after he launched the invasion of
Ukraine connectors Western sanctions
imposed on Russia since the war
complicated its collaborations in space
with Europe and the us because of
Western sanctions a lot of the
corporation that used to take part in
terms of space projects they have come
to an end and also because of Technology
export bans Russia cannot receive a lot
of the electronics and other technology
that it would have in the past from
European nations that supported its
space program so this is extremely
significant
for India there are political and
financial reasons driving its mission to
the lunar South Pole the successful
Mission could boost prime minister
Narendra modi's election campaign early
next year these kind of missions adds to
the national pride Prime Minister Modi
is going to tell his voters how the
country has reached the moon and which
would make to his benefit
the Indian space agency works on a
shoestring budget in February the
government slashed funding for the
Departments of space by eight percent to
1.5 billion dollars in comparison NASA's
budget for 2023 is more than 25 billion
dollars
India is hoping to get a lot of foreign
collaborations in terms of like offer
offers to launch commercial satellites
so it relies on these foreign
collaborations to support its space
missions
India's successful landing on the lunar
South Pole could change its standing in
the global Space Race especially in Asia
India's position as a global space Power
would definitely be reinforced
definitely puts India ahead of countries
like Japan and Korea and just behind
China
meanwhile Russia still has a way to go
to catch up with the US and China it's
not the be-all and end-all for Russia
there are other Lunas Luna 26 and Luna
27 they both depend on electronics from
the west and for as long as sanctions
continue it's going to be difficult for
Russia to obtain the kind of technology
that it needs to continue collaborating
and ensuring that it is number one as it
wants to be in the space race
foreign